[Music]
a couple years ago christian and i
directed our first short it was a
modernization of the abraham and isaac
story from the bible and we reached out
to a man whom we both admired the actor
and playwright wallace shawn
so i emailed him and sent him the script
and he wrote back
the most thoughtful
and lengthy response
saying no it was such a beautiful
rejection
but they're basically the reason he said
no is because
he
doesn't want to spend time doing things
anymore and he doesn't like getting
things and he values time so much it was
a very life is short kind of response
that's true but there was part of me
that was like if you just put the time
into doing this one scene
that you're putting into writing this
rejection
is so eloquent you might as well just do
the scene
i think it would have taken longer to
write the rejection than do the scenes
it's true
yeah it was all about how he wanted to
use his time more wisely and like he
didn't want to take him an hour to write
that no you're not considering that's
how bright he is he probably wrote my
dinner with andre in like seven hours
and the time it takes to eat at dinner
with andre yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
and with me as always uh is a man i
often eat dinner with
christian long my dinner with christian
my podcast with christian
that we should rename this show if
people love that reference that's a very
popular reference you know i've never
seen my dinner with andre and i either
both now have to have seen my dinner
with andre but i've always been like
i've been meaning to for so long i know
i want to see but it's one of those
movies that i know is important and uh
probably like very obviously culturally
significant and probably really good
well-acted and written
but it just seems like a commitment you
know to watch two people have dinner a
movie about it because that's the whole
movie it's just two people having dinner
i know i mean it would require real
focus yeah
i mean it'd be great to have him on the
podcast
or on i don't know if he'll want to
spend time doing this podcast he made it
very clear that he doesn't like but that
is going to be nice to ask him so we can
get a really like wonderful eloquent but
it's funny after that that letter that
we got i was like oh man that that this
guy's the best that he only does stuff
that he really wants to do and he's
thoughtful and kind in his response but
then i remember like a week later i saw
him pop up in some like super cheesy oh
yeah not hallmark movie but well it was
like a hallmark it was hallmark movie
adjacent yeah and i was like wait a
second but in his defense he's probably
getting a lot of money yeah we weren't
paying him anything like it was just a
favor i barely i had met him like maybe
once that's true why are we talking
about wallace sean i'll tell you because
our guest today
recently co-starred with him
in a movie that no one has seen yet
and maybe a movie that no one will ever
see yes because it's woody allen's
latest movie i doubt it will come out
here but um our guest today is gina
gershon uh one of my one of like the
greats
and most versatile i think actresses she
doesn't get a lot of credit for that but
she has had
uh
so many she's done so many different
roles like a real character actor yeah
one of her no she's in one of her nose
one of her roles she's most known for is
uh is bound which is like a iconic movie
for snf aficionados
and that movie uh among a few other
projects that she did has made her a
real gay icon yes a guy con a guy um
maybe more specifically a lesbian icon
would you say uh i don't know no you
know what i i forgot to tell you this i
went to a gentleman's club with her once
i went to a strip club with gina once i
can't believe we didn't talk about this
in the interview totally forgot about
this in when we were shooting in
albuquerque and uh which is the movie i
we worked together on this movie it's
the first time i met her i don't go to
strip clubs anymore i have been to very
few and i'm not just saying that to
look good um but i have never seen such
a response he thinks the lady don't
protest too much that's true
but i'll never attract the women anymore
i don't go there anymore um sorry it's
interesting but well i've never seen
such a response that oh really the
dancers
all gravitated toward her and like
because she was show girls showgirls
yeah yeah and she i said was it like
this every time because gina said she
does occasionally go to those places of
illegal repute
and um
she was like yeah i get it
this is common they were they went
bananas for her and wanted to give her
special dances and do stuff well i would
say i mean show girls is such an iconic
yeah in general such a cult classic but
if specifically for strippers obviously
right strippers must love show girls and
she was the one of the leads in that
yeah that was that's what made her big
break that's what made her famous that
movie was
huge i think she's also been in like you
said bound show girls like ah hundreds
like she works all the time she has a
recurring role in curb enthusiasm where
she plays um a hasidic jewish dry
cleaner yeah and she's incredible what
what are you saying larry yeah so funny
yeah she's so good so good on that um
and christian and i actually worked with
her on a movie in new orleans which we
recently referenced with louise guzman
who was also in that and uh we had a lot
of fun with her down there i do remember
one scene she wanted to eat in these
scenes right didn't she always want to
eat she was very aware of
what angle her face looked the best yeah
yes is that fair to say yeah and and you
know i don't think i mean she's been
doing it for so long that she is but
it's really a pro when it comes to
knowing her angles yes and it's
something i
i didn't quite understand because to us
it seemed like she was beautiful from
all these different angles
for me it's like i don't have any bad
angles oh no so it didn't even make
sense to me that she would have a better
angle than another uh yeah i'm just not
used to that when i look in the mirror
it's all perfect um
i met her on this movie dreamland we
talked about she played my mom which was
strange she was not unlike
leah thompson playing my mom in another
movie or someone else well oh and um
oh friend friend dressed yeah she's
another in a long list of actresses who
should be insulted that they played your
mom and on galaxy quest it was heidi
swedberg who played um george costanza's
uh fiance fiance seinfeld and and again
i was like and we both we all of those
actresses i would say the one thing they
have in common is that they're way too
young to be playing and and pretty yeah
yeah attractive yeah so let's get into
it okay and let's talk about um
how we met and all the things and our
guest today gina gershon
life could be a dream
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
okay so you you brought me this which is
so sweet brought me a cookie you know i
i try every day not to eat these because
they live across you know the street
they live in my neighborhood and they're
the best cookies ever supposedly they're
oprah's favorite cookies your chocolate
you should taste one right now do you
like chocolate chip cookies who doesn't
who doesn't who doesn't like chocolate
[ __ ] don't like chocolate chip
cookies i don't like puppies or the
beetles either i mean i'm very snobby
when it comes to cookies and donuts and
things like that where's your donut um
place you know i like california donut
king i'm a california donut person i
like
in la you know how you drive home and
it's two in the morning or whatever the
mini malls the mini malls are the best
damn donuts yep they're just old school
they're so good i don't like it when
they start getting so fancy i know it's
just [ __ ] i don't want bacon on the
top of my diet don't like that [ __ ] i
don't get it stupid you can't just do
like an old fashioned with a really good
chocolate you know that really good sort
of frosting that's it then you know what
thank you you're not a donut place uh am
i allowed to curse on your show [ __ ] no
clean it up clean it up by the way um we
should start rolling are you rolling
stupid after someone says something like
profound or good i'm like oh man
i know like the way you tricked me to
come over you're like hey do you want to
just hang out and also i'm like wait
what are microphones doing here thank
you oh you weren't supposed to see those
it's like you didn't hide the microphone
so great um should we explain why we
talk like this people are like why do
they talk like they're really good
points that's a really good point we
always talk like that yeah um so gina
and i whenever we see each other we
start talking i guess from napoleon
dynamite yeah because we did that movie
together around the time napoleon right
when napoleon dynamite came out and so
for some reason we couldn't stop talking
like this stupid you know i've since
worked with that guy i've worked with
john heater
oh you have yeah yeah and you talked to
him like that of course um
and he what was great about him was that
he was so game to do it himself because
everyone probably does it to him i don't
know i like his attitude does he really
like that i kind of want to think he's
really like that's the other thing he's
not that different
you know like why does everyone talk
like me all the time
yeah i don't see why it's so much a
character um but he's a very smart sweet
guy john is i should add um
we so we worked together first on uh a
movie called dreamland which i'm sure
everyone saw everyone saw it uh
we it was in 2004. i don't know that we
were in it because when you did a little
post on your instagram about it you
failed to mention oh they'll know well
you weren't in the picture so
use a different picture
do you like doing instagram you're good
on it you do a lot of uh
you're prolific but but am i pro you
know what i started out not wanting to
do anything i don't even i only got a
twitter account just because someone was
using my name
and and facebook and i thought ugh i
don't want
someone pretending so i just i got it
i'm not very good at twitter and then i
got instagram a few years ago when i had
a book coming out um and they told me i
had to i don't know i wasn't as involved
and then when i i started doing
riverdale last year or the year before
oh man that's huge and you realize it's
such a young person's medium totally
yeah as soon as i was like announced all
of a sudden i'm like wow i'm really
popular today it was like
it went from like nothing to like a lot
of people oh my god as soon as you have
a lot of people you kind of
catch that
icky addiction of like oh i want to get
more people eyes next and it becomes an
icky game yeah they're very i don't
think anyone's immune to that
well you know a friend of mine
who i really like and oprah he went off
of it a year ago and i'm so like
impressed with him that he just didn't
doesn't do it obama
obama's on it he's on it that's right
that's right who's so your friend just
quit it completely
ben sinclair
from high maintenance and i keep saying
when your show comes on you probably go
back on it again just like i just went
off everything because
it was taking too much time and why give
all that content away and because he's
writing he's doing the show and i have
to say i spend so much time i waste so
much time
on it where i should be reading i should
be writing or playing music or whatever
that's actually really comforting to
hear you say that because i i know i
feel really ashamed of the time i wasted
i feel ashamed too like if we started an
instagram anonymous it would be like
and like i'm all a shame but i realized
very quickly
for better or worse
it's really between unless riverdale
kids i mean between 13 to 18 all of a
sudden i was getting thousands and
thousands like so many
um
and they're the ones who really comment
and now that i haven't been on the show
for like the last nine months or however
long it's been i'm starting to lose
people isn't that funny yeah so it's all
the so the show so the showgirls fans
aren't necessarily uh no i think it's a
that's an older creature they must be
your favorite demographic of fans i
would imagine the show girls crowds what
are they like what are they that's
probably not my favorite demo i mean
it's the most colorful demographic you
know it's like they're really quoting
lines to you and stuff quoting lines
like you know i love it like it's like
you know
but like bound is a very oh yeah they're
much more serious usually the ladies
who have like leather clad yeah but that
makes me feel good because then they're
like oh my god you really helped us come
out and like i feel ha i feel good about
that and face off i could always tell
them a mile away oh really
you know it's just
it's really funny how you could tell
different food groups um i mean i'm just
happy when anyone likes anything totally
did you know and i didn't know this the
first thing you did was pretty in pink
i know that's so cool i know i don't
know that movie as well as i should
because i love 80s movies it was i was
such a small partner and it was like one
of my first things really but it was
john hughes yeah john hughes so that
must have been huge for you at the time
hugh john
well it would have been a fight
it was so clever i could see why you
have a podcast you're so smart
[Laughter]
so how you were born in outlet you were
raised in l.a in the valley i was raised
in the valley was when you watch boogie
nights is it like that's what it was
like i mean minus the i don't remember
it except when i left the valley which i
had to leave the valley at some point
because i was getting in a lot of
trouble oh and i was just because i was
really bored and i didn't scratch the
good age
i was stimulating i wasn't stimulated
enough and i was getting into trouble my
parents they're just like we have to get
her out of her my friends were either
like going to drug rehab getting busted
but one of my best friends whose name i
won't say
please i'm not going to um
but i found out later after i graduated
and you know we lost touch because i
didn't really talk to anyone after that
so much but she turned into a prostitute
was doing porn
i don't know if she was doing foreign
but she was definitely a prostitute i
mean there was a certain element of that
part of the valley that wait but you
know what so at what point did you leave
the valley 15. well i left at 15. i went
to because i went to beverly high oh
that's like
it was either that or a girls school
they're like we have to get you out of
here
why was beverly high a better choice i
mean like um
because first of all it is a really good
school and it's kind of like a private
school and my mom was working there a
lot she was doing interior decorating
and stuff and so we just got my aunt and
uncle my cousins were there so we just
got one was like you know
uh the slums of beverly hills like
little place and my brother and sister
had already graduated they were already
off to college and my dad was traveling
a lot so it was you know closer to the
airport yeah and then they just thought
this is where you should go to school so
it wasn't god i did you know it was such
a it was a really great school and i met
people there who i ended up working with
in my life oh i bet a lot of you you
might have to get a little closer to
that how's the mic how's the volume here
you forgot to tell me to put on my
stupid headphones okay well yeah this
might help yeah i could hear so i could
put on my radio voice
you do have a great voice i almost said
sultry this is my sultry radio voice
when i want to talk like this oh really
but i usually just kind of talk
let's just do our natural places all
right say like
the valley was like so ranked and so i
had to get out of it and then i went to
betterly and i was like oh my god like
drugs but beverly must have so it wasn't
necessarily like a disciplinarian thing
that they wanted you to be more
disciplined and have more structure by
going to beverly it was just a better
school i was just really depressed in
the valley and i i think your
environment really
affects you and you know i was at home
alone because my parents were off
working and my brother and sister were
you know older and they're already at
school
luckily i started doing plays i realized
i could do that and that kind of kept me
off the streets that's interesting
because i romanticized that part of the
[ __ ] that the valley in the 70s i
romanticize it because of what i've seen
in the movies you know um probably
mostly boogie nights uh yeah what what
you roman but that if it's really like
that that's not the healthiest yeah
exactly it's quite dark it's not that
there's not a lot to do i just think the
people at my school they weren't doing
stuff so i was like going to pinball
arcade and smoking a lot of pot idle
hands idle hands and then i started
dancing which saved me a little bit and
then once i started acting i saw people
that definitely helped me a lot but then
i kept getting
i mean cass is the lead and this and
that and this oh so you took to it right
away
i took to it right away i didn't have
anyone around me who was stimulating me
so at least i had that and then as soon
as i my parents were like we got to get
you out of here because i was just
starting to get in a lot of trouble
and often i not turned against my
friends but it was just that weird thing
that i was just getting depressed if i'm
not around creative people i get kind of
depressed yeah i'm one of those people
like right now i'm getting few no you
see so depressed well
i'll try to be more creative try to do
something interesting
no but then but when i went to beverly i
was excited that there's a guy playing
music in the cafeteria and i'm like that
guy's great like and then i thought oh
let's go sing songs together and it's
lemony kravitz oh my god he was romeo
blue or what was his name
romeo blue
what that was his stage name and then we
were we were too young to be on the main
stage so we were in the pit chorus
together saying like okay we're going to
be up on the big stage one day oh my
gosh you know but you could tell there
were like talented people and then i did
my first um
we did a play there that got moved to
the coronet theater so it's my first
drill
professional show that i had it was you
know tina landau who was my best friend
she wrote it and directed it music
daughter no that was susie landau yeah i
did antigone and i did all those plays
with and then martin
i ended up meeting him he was my first
real teacher no tina landa who just did
um spongebob bob squarepants on
broadcast yeah and she does tons of
she's brilliant tina's brilliant i hear
i know i
hear these stories about beverly hills
schools like that are malibu high and
they're all it's like
one after another of like
you know well-known people well-regarded
people it was just people who either i
think parents are in the business yeah
sure which you know i don't think means
much on itself but it was people who
were very
goal-oriented and
you know i was dancing with my friends
who i'm still friends with now and then
i was doing plays that were high level
when i went to audition in college it
was easy compared to the you know
beverly auditions really and you went to
emerson you went to in that's in i went
to emerson first just for a year and
then i didn't really love it there and
then i ended up going to nyu i
auditioned i got in in the second year
you didn't love boston or emerson
i didn't love emerson although looking
back i would have done it differently i
really wanted to act i was so focused on
acting but at emerson i should have
taken more writing and comedy writing
and the stuff that they were kind of
known for
um and the acting wasn't that at that
moment i think it's got a lot better
it's supposed to be good they're
supposed to be good now but nyu of
course is one of the best nyu was like
the teachers i really wanted to study
with were there and it just felt like a
different level but i was glad i went to
boston before going to new york for the
first year of going away yeah was it
hard for you to be away you were you
close with your parents
i wanted to get out of la
i went to san francisco the year before
my 12th grade between high school i i
kind of lied and got into act oh wow so
i was living there and going back to los
angeles
i really didn't like it i just thought i
don't belong here interesting and i had
really dark hair and you know gothy i
wasn't no not gothy i looked more like
you know some middle eastern woman
before i plucked my eyebrows like my
hair i lit in my big moon face
my baby fat and pretty pink you can look
i kind of like that look still oh my
baby fat and um but at the time i wasn't
you know they were looking for like
american girls and they'd be like oh
you're middle eastern or you're this i
was too exotic
so i was either too
you know ethnic then yeah i'm not ethnic
enough it's you know that's how all that
stuff goes but um
from the play i i had agents saying do
you want to do a tv show we'll represent
you really at that age yeah wow i was
really good
good i was so
talented no but i wanted to go to
college i really wanted to go to school
and study and not just be like oh i'm
doing a sitcom now now what because i'm
an actress and
you
evidence of that is that you were both a
drama and philosophy major i did
philosophy and i did psychology oh
psychology yeah i was interested in all
those things i mean i loved school and
the problem yeah actually at beverly was
an awesome it was so professional i had
to give up dancing and i was playing
sports then and just to totally do plays
and in college
i wanted to do writing and i want to do
directing and i wanted to do philosophy
and psychology and there wasn't enough
time to do everything but then i was a
bfa acting major so you know i had to
dedicate a lot of my time to that was
there a part of you that thought like
well what am i doing here i i just want
to i want to get out there and act i
want to get out there and like see
you had that offer from the agent you
know what i went when i went to act they
had really good teachers there and
when you do your final thing this guy
david hammond who was actually
at yale and then tina ended up going to
yale tina was like my best friend so i'm
like where are you going let's kind of
be here each other so i was going to the
classes there and seeing oh cool what
was going on there um and he was like
you have to go to school don't just go
right away really learn and like educate
yourself and i'm so happy yeah because
the parts that i was getting offered
even when i was in school you know it
was like you know the friday the 13th or
oh yeah or you know the flash dance was
one thing i'm excited about yeah yeah it
was but
they were definitely it wasn't substance
it was a substance and like i would have
been exploited you know because i looked
older than i did at the time and i just
thought this isn't really what i want
and i yeah and thank god i don't think i
could really act then i think i was okay
but i kind of learned to do yeah what i
do later on i look back at some of the
early stuff i did and i think oh man i i
kind of don't you wish you knew what you
know now and you yeah yeah
yeah were you jewish just culturally did
you grow up jewish but was it your
parents were religious
okay
yeah and movement yeah um you play a
very convincing orthodox jewish woman on
curb your enthusiasm
that was so i mean i didn't even i just
made that up on the spot i don't really
know i was really i thought i was
playing myself and they said oh no
you're going to play this i went oh oh
my god i said just make up an accent and
i just started talking that way they
said great let's film it and we just
made it up he seems like he gets a
genuine kick out of you i i can tell
sometimes he has a hard time kind of
covering up which is great because
he's able to do that on the show his his
persona on the show is such that like if
he starts if he's tickled by someone or
if he starts kind of laughing at what
someone's doing it it's okay that he
reveals that it was so
satisfying and he would laugh at my
jokes
i'd make something up and he'd laugh and
i was like great but then it was like
dude now we have to do it again because
you're really just improvising with the
camera on both and yeah and one day we
had so much fun though that they're not
using two cameras they are except he
starts laughing yeah you know we have to
kind of do it again yeah yeah um and one
day we went down some rabbit hole we
just kept going going and the next day
they were like uh can you come back i
don't you guys were having a lot of fun
but it made like no sense ugh
i want those outtakes so badly right now
it was just
it was just the most
i mean we did a couple you did a bunch
of episodes they ended up having me
three times they kept bringing me back i
was trying to talk i said can't we just
do an offshoot like yeah the horny hussy
just i want to do my own show and i want
to work like this yeah it's the most fun
it's so much fun to work that way as
long as you have people who are good and
you know what they're doing you have
someone on the outside watching going
okay just keep that part now you know
who directs you and despite from what
you're doing is that something that you
had done before had you done a lot of
improv in the past before that show no
oh that was really the first time wow
but i i guess i i knew i could do it i
liked playing games and improved games
and um
but then jeff garland saw me do a roast
for dennis leary that's how i got it oh
really and yeah it really went crazy and
then i got really angry and so i said
i'm changing my whole monologue and i'm
changing the song and it was live wait
wait and i just went nuts and afterwards
he was like you have to do our show i
was like [ __ ] you i was so mad wait wait
how'd it change why'd you get angry
well because i'd never done a roast
before
and dennis was a good friend of mine and
he said hey they're doing a comedy
central roast for me
will you be on it i said of course and
he said well you sing i said sure just
give me the song and you know i'll do
whatever you want he was like kind of my
big brother you know i really adored him
and
it's like a roasty song like dennis
leary is a fat head no i well i kept
saying what are the lyrics like what's
he said oh we'll get him to you we'll
get you it's like a month and then two
weeks i'm like dennis i really need the
song he's like don't worry it's fine
there'll be you know teleprompters i
said dennis it's live like i need to
know it's not a roast of me it's not
roast me like i need to it's like and
there's gonna be dancing girls oh you're
gonna be singing i said dude just give
me the song so i at least know what i'm
doing sure like three days before they
give it to me and then it went from punk
rock to kind of dean martin style they
kept changing i said you have to just
nail this down because i need to know
what i'm doing that's i'm going to get
anxious that's a lot it goes from like
an ask a favor to like that's a lot to
ask well they were figuring it out i was
trying to be cool and finally we had it
and i had dancing girls and blah blah
blah and it was the first i was the
first one up and i had a top hat and
just like a little outfit and you know
i'd never
done a roast and so they said just do a
little speech about dennis and i'm like
you know dennis is like my brother i
love him it was so earnest oh my god oh
so you i had no [ __ ] clue it was like
a good rose it was like an ant it was
like a sweet thing and then i said okay
let's sing the song it's a toast it was
a toast not a roast
and and then we did the little dance
number and as soon as it was over i was
so relieved that it went okay
i get off stage i was like oh thank god
and i down at tequila and i start to
smoke a cigarette because i was just i
was really nervous
i was trying to keep it together yeah
and i think i might have downed another
tequila like oh thank god that's over
with and then they came back and they
said guess what you have to do it again
i said why thinking oh god let's do it
now before this tequila really hits me
they said because the top hat was
shading your eyes and i said great let's
just do it right now they said no no
it's live so you have to wait until the
very end of the show and i'll do it oh
my god and i'm like really you mean like
when people want to leave i'm going to
have to say oh no stay people let me do
my act again because your lighting was
off yeah that sucks but it was dennis i
was trying to be cool yeah okay they
said why don't you just watch the show
and then
you know we'll do it at the end yeah so
i'm sitting with my friend and i'm
watching the roast and there's a lot of
like like serious
and not only are they roasting the [ __ ]
out of dennis they're going after me oh
no and i'm the only girl so you know
they could have a field day with that
and as they're going after me i'm like
wait a second as i'm starting to drink
one more tequila and another because i'm
getting really pissed i'm like wait a
second my friend's like that's what they
do they roast everyone i'm like those
[ __ ]
and so by the time
i had to go up again
i was i was a little bit crocked oh i
gotta see this i wasn't croc but i was a
little i had a little accomplishment you
had a yeah you have it you had an edge i
had an edge and i just said just vamp
i'm changing my whole speech i said and
girls i'm changing the dancing a little
bit and so all of a sudden it became
this nice thing to and i just like i
don't remember what i said but i started
nailing the guys and like and you
wouldn't say that because that would
make you an [ __ ] wouldn't it and what
about you i mean i just went and you
jeffrey ross you jeffrey ross thank you
jeffrey
i mean i think i went off and then i
sang the song and it was much angrier it
must have been but probably more in
keeping with a real like a roast and not
a toast i don't know i've never seen her
anyway afterwards jeff garland who i
didn't know i'd never seen him he
laughed he said because i think that
might have been the funniest thing i've
ever seen oh my gosh like you have to do
our show i'm like [ __ ] you why didn't
you protect me
you were there he's like no no trust me
and i was really busy that week and i
remember they called and they said they
want you to do curb and i just didn't
know what it was oh you hadn't seen it i
hadn't seen it oh wow and weirdly enough
of all people i was with rick rubin i
remember and rick said i don't care what
you're doing this is the most important
thing you'll do all year it's funny i
said yeah but i have this he said just
it's okay cancel it and i said okay and
then
yeah they said oh if you could only play
the hasidic jew at the cleaners one more
time and i'm like what they said no no
no everyone's like don't worry you just
play yourself and i got there and they
said no we really want you to play this
real character and then we just made it
up and i'd never i've never done that
crazy well it was so fun
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men valued for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
when you transferred uh to pursue acting
at what point did you discover you i
know you did work at uh circle in the
square with mammoth is that well when i
went to nyu yeah that's when i started
studying with him it was a class and he
at some point chose like 20 of us and he
said i'm going to have a thing over the
summer
here these are guys are the ones i want
to come and that was the beginning of
the atlantic theater company oh my god
he's one of my favorites and yeah i've
heard i i just i'm fascinated by him and
his place what were you aware of him you
had read his place oh yeah yeah i knew
of him and i thought he was a really
incredible teacher
i learned a lot um
although when it was
time to like
do they're like okay this is gonna be
the company and you guys write this
i i mean i liked everyone but i knew
they weren't my people for some reason
and um
i'm not even sure if i got ass back i
have to i can't i kind of have a murky
feeling about it what's mammoth like as
a teacher because i know his whole ethos
is all acting ethos is that you just say
the words you say the the the
text dictates everything i think that's
where i had a problem yeah that would be
time oh no i remember what happened um
yeah so basically he's like you know oh
strasbourg feel the music with your toes
and he was kind of saying and i i
understand he's just like do the words
get your intention figure out what
you're doing blah blah blah which to me
is like 101. you have to do all that
stuff and you instinctively do it anyway
and it's like it's a good technique
um but then when i went back um
you know anyone who says oh these other
people i'm like i'm going to go study at
strasbourg now i'm going to go study
with playwrights and so i i did what you
weren't supposed to do at nyu move
around but oh and i would think that
would be a good thing to kind of sample
they don't let you but i did it anyway
and um
because i'm a rubber yeah you're right
i'm a rebel browser no i i i just yeah i
don't know i saw your roast i was cute
yeah no i was curious about it and then
as soon as i graduated college um
you know i kind of had my own gang of
friends from nyu and just from around
you know like fisher stephens oh yeah
you're kidding
and you know frank lazy and bubble and
all of a sudden we just said [ __ ] it
let's just start our own theater company
and so we start naked angels oh that's
right that's yeah oh it was born out of
that well i mean i didn't go that way
and i kept i loved the idea of it but
something didn't feel totally fit
perfectly for me and i thought i mean i
do think they really go by david's
i think there was so much it was like
the stanford meisner message method and
i think it's really great but i also
wanted to do big emotional crazy [ __ ]
that didn't really fit into what he was
doing as much yeah and so i wanted to
learn
methody stuff and sensory work and and
so you started doing actual play were
you doing originally where kenny naked
angels with kenny lonergan wright there
and oh yeah yeah they were all
john robin bates kenny lonegan warren
light wow we had an insane
group of writers wow and um we're all
just doing one action we're all just
saying let's put on a show because no
one was hiring us and would you say of
the original members of the naked angels
your farts were the worst
or i had the silent ones they were the
smelliest that's right for sure yeah no
one knew it was me they were sneaky
right i would usually like you know
blame like fisher sure it's easy to
blame fisheries he is blind he just
looks like a farter let's face it um at
what point after that did the film
career really kick into high gear was it
show girls no show girls was a little
bit later i mean i had done the sinatra
mini series oh okay so you were working
consistently uh i was working i was
either doing theater i started the latc
in la or i was doing um like dumb movies
and you know yeah i was just trying to
do stuff and then but show girls is
definitely the biggest high-profile
thing i noticed you had never done
anything longer for uh than six years
you've never done a series like a six
year long one of those long term
commitment issues i said why i was
wondering if that's what it was no you
know what i actually and i i think it's
one of the one things
i'm not a big believer in regret because
i think things happen for a reason oh i
am i love regret but but go on do you do
what do you regret oh don't get me
started really certain relationships you
know yeah
not getting into the relationships but
staying in them i suppose yeah
because of my own guilt and whatever
reasons that it now seems so silly and
petty i know but i guess you just
weren't ready to get out yeah but it's
like come on you know i know it's a
waste of time waste of time i know i
have a couple of those yeah let's talk
about them let's not we'll talk about
that afterwards
uh well but yeah i especially when it
comes to doing a character like the idea
of doing a character for more than you
know let's say like a year or two years
that to me seems like it might not be as
fulfilling yeah i mean i was nervous
about that and then uh my first series
that i did that i really did
was a david kelly show and i didn't
really want to do it and i everyone's
like oh david kelly i'm like yeah he's
great but i just thought the part was
and then i went in
and they ended up offering it to me and
i just talked about really i just had a
really bad breakup and so i was in la
and i just wanted to get to new york
where my friends were and where i felt
safer for some reason was your family's
still in l.a at that time
but my relationship in my whole memories
it was a big breakup so i was just like
i need to get out yeah but then dave i
was like i don't know david
had he done allie mcbeal yeah yeah oh
okay who's coming off of that oh wow and
so i said i i kind of like the guy's
part he's like great you could be the
guy
and i kept saying you know i'm gonna get
sick of playing the same part he said
well you'll be something different every
week and i'm like anything i said i mean
there's a reason why he's david kelly
i'm like [ __ ] i can't turn this down and
so i said yes and that's how he
convinced michelle pfeiffer to be
eventually she was like fine fine i'll
be with you because i'll make it really
fun he's like the nicest i heard i heard
he's great and we kind of made a side
deal i'm saying i'm really in a weird
place right now when if i get scared
about being on this show and what if i
want what if i get he said anytime
you're sick of it just give me the word
and you'll stop it and everyone's like
oh you're stuck and i said i trust this
guy and it was fun i got to play
different parts and i didn't realize how
great i had it with him but he was doing
like four other shows so when he wrote
it he was there i loved it when he
wasn't i was like wait a second and i
didn't even know what a show runner was
they'd be like what's with your hair i'm
like what's with your shoes like i
didn't have the right attitude
what um so after a year i got out of i
said yeah i gotta get i was very
depressed doing it what was the show
called it's called snoops oh yeah i
remember sue not just because not to the
show i was just snap i remember oh snap
no i was just in a bad headspace during
that time and i just i think i was just
too affected i couldn't think straight
but looking back
i we should have kept going we should
have been like let's change it become a
producer like he was so and i didn't
understand how easy how hard that was to
get someone like him yeah to do a show
now i'm trying to get a showdown i'm
like oh my god david yeah i don't even
take my calls
[Laughter]
david remember remember me you used to
like me you said we could work together
again i guess you lied so what happened
to the show the show just folded yeah oh
wow wow so now you're what what kind of
thing are you looking to do now what
kind of show um if david kelly's
listening if david's pretend i'm david
kelly
so gina he doesn't talk about that i
don't know where that came from
hold on michelle's texting me again
that is awesome
that is like the worst imitation ever
i've never heard him talk
um i don't know it'd be fun to create a
show i just want to be at this point on
a show maybe not so much as impravi as
kurt but certainly the freedom
with really good people who i know and
who i like and um you know i've sold a
couple shows but then they've never
actually gone so i'm really trying to
figure out what i've done i mean the
last few shows i've done have ended up
being musical stuff that i did at a car
you didn't you weren't here when i did
my residency the cafe car last night no
no i heard about how long was it so fun
it was two weeks and i wrote a one-woman
show that i keep thinking maybe i should
bring that back and do it somewhere but
oh i get bored of things easily but i
like doing music and i did another
one-woman show that turned into a book
the
might remember my cat book
how
how i found my [ __ ] and lost my mind in
search of cleo it was about my cat yeah
see i have no merry christmas
but i did wrote a one woman show about
that that was i really liked i'd like to
do something like that again something
involving [ __ ] something involving my
[ __ ] you can't like you know
as one is and does no i like doing music
but you wrote a children's book right
with your brother yeah it was like a
young adult book oh what what inspired
that he came up with this idea and he
told me about it he said oh i wrote this
book i had this idea and i was like wow
that's really great where did you steal
that idea from he said i didn't i wrote
it and he handed me these pages
and i said it's insulting that you're
super stolen well i didn't know he was a
writer yeah i said when did you start
writing what does he do um he's kind of
an entrepreneur and he's
he has some crazy thing on
uh
the internet now with color and
um it's pretty out there but it's pretty
great
zen color okay um but anyway to make a
long story short i looked at it i said
you could write this is a book i said
this is a great movie and he never wrote
it and then it just kept bothering me
after three years i'm like you need to
write that thing i want to make a movie
out of it
and it was like back and forth you do it
you do it and yeah finally we just wrote
it together and oh cool after about a
year and a half um and then it turned
into a book and then spielberg bought it
like before it even went out frank
spielberg frank spielberg no stephen
stephen
spielberg
saw it oh he was going to go on the
market and so then and richard
lagravenese was going to do the
screenplay we had kind of a dream team
and then it went into that development
hell and i kept going wait why are you
making it like this familiar story
and where is it now i mean i actually
own everything i took the rights back
and so
i do something like that yeah i forget i
keep saying i have always sent it to
david kelly i know senator david kelly
it's cute but then you know it was
before um diary of a teenage kid and
before twilight okay and there's there's
there's you know vampires and werewolves
and it's kind of a kid who cries wolf
it's really cute yeah but i feel like
there's just such um there's like an
unending appetite for stuff like that i
know i think i need to get an agent i i
know i don't have an agent no what i
know isn't that crazy are you wondering
why aren't i going out more oh i forgot
why why don't you have an
agent because
you booked this gig sweet gig
i saw you and you you said hey do it i
said okay oh right like all my jobs yeah
i know i need to get i decided today i
need to get an agent but a good agent
well yeah ideally um you were an actress
in hollywood throughout the 80s 90s 2000
you've i mean i'm sure you've seen your
share of deplorable behavior that is you
know thankfully coming to light with a
lot of these uh you know i kind of
jealous i i had maybe the closest with
one time i have to say like at the
audition the guy said something creepy
like oh you're so cute why don't you get
up and walk around and i i was doing
theater then i was like i just need to
make some money yeah and immediately i
was like ugh if you're gonna be gross
i'm just going to leave wow and he's
like i'll offer you the lead i'm like
see you later good luck and i left and
guess what i still got the part no [ __ ]
and then on the set i'm like you know
we're going to get along great if you
just don't talk to me i was just there
for two days to make quick money but i i
don't know i always
maybe it's cause i had a big brother or
something or i grew up in the valley and
a lot of weird stuff was going on i mean
i just always kind of learned how to
really i've gotten very close to very
bad situations and i always had to kind
of
get out of situations and being very
vocal and very direct and getting out of
there and you had probably maybe because
of europe bringing a sixth sense of of
when there was
trouble or danger uh a foot or in the
air yeah i'd been in a couple situations
where you kind of learn how to defend
yourself a little bit and but i have to
say
i have to say i think out of all of this
you know i just hope like remember when
like just say no to drugs you know i
just hope that girls because everything
is shifting as you're growing up and
boys whoever you know as a young person
or a vulnerable person sure you need to
really learn to look someone in the eye
and say don't do that right and because
it makes all the difference in the world
and i understand how people are scared
of that but you know also i have to say
even
i think when i got show girls you know i
was so excited because i thought oh my
god you know i grew up a dancer yeah and
it was like i thought it was gonna be
like fosse like movement yeah sure you
know i was looking at you know basic
instinct and i was thinking had done
basically and just before that was this
movie well and all of his dutch films
yeah yeah he was obsessed with his
dot-coms and i thought oh my god this
guy's such a great director and
basically anything that i thought was
cool
and so when and you know like i said i
had grown up being like a modern dancer
so like dancing around like that it
wasn't that big of a deal for me because
i thought i'm a good dancer i could i
could marry that with acting oh my god
this is fantastic and it's a great part
a great part you know in a part that i
didn't think i was gonna get i thought i
was too
young so i like kind of lied about my
agents that i was much older because at
first i read i'm like which part am i
playing i'm not old enough to play oh
yeah you're supposed to be like the kind
of more seasoned game i was like it was
like all about eve and i thought wait a
second i'm gonna be
margo instead of eve like
so i think i put on so much makeup and i
think i lied about my age and i just
thought this is a total crazy long shot
and i think i'd heard like madonna and
all these different people wanted to get
it but i just thought i love this and i
you know i'm gonna go for it yeah um but
in all that
after i got it um
it was like a big deal it was a big you
know sure i didn't even have an agent
then isn't that crazy i had to leave my
agents because they kept going now we
got you friday the 13th i'm like you
guys i just got this movie called show
girls and i just left thinking i'm gonna
someone else needs to make this deal
because yeah wow this is very strange um
friday the 13th then must have been like
friday 13th part like six or seven or
eight
and i didn't and weirdly enough i
thought it was so exploitive i'm like oh
my god i have to show my boobs that's
funny right i'm gonna do show girls
instead so when i got show girls right
a lot of like executive like male
executives they kept coming up to me
saying oh so
like i heard you got showgirls that's a
big deal and they'd be totally looking
down my body oh like in a very you just
did it to me and it made me somewhat
uncomfortable right it was kind of like
this and i would unconsciously or
consciously like cross my arms and be
like oh yeah yeah it's really cool you
know all of this and i'd start listening
you know you know spatters you know uh
soldier of orange and you know all of
his dutch films i said he's so
incredible and i'd get very intellectual
about it yeah feeling very uncomfortable
and objectified immediately objectified
and i didn't quite know how to deal with
it and then i remember
somehow i remember the fourth time or
fifth time someone did that just
something snapped in me
and i remember looking at the guy like
right in the eye like oh yeah man i'm
like sleeping with girls i'm sleeping
with guys i'm dancing naked it's gonna
be great
and i just stared at him like that yeah
she's just staring at me and it's yeah
and he visibly shrunk down and he walked
away and i thought
okay so just look at someone in the eye
and just say what you want and you're
grounded hold your ground and they're
not gonna [ __ ] with you
and i just i sometimes i just hope that
oh that's so interesting i wish you know
like a lot of these a lot of people need
to learn that lesson so to protect
themselves because listen all this is
great but there's still creepy people of
course of course
like don't get in the car when you're
little you know of course well this is
that's why this movement i mean i think
probably one of the best byproducts of
it is
it will
empower women to be more capable of
behaving that way i would imagine of
holding their ground instead of like the
fear of losing out on a part or because
that's the other thing like that you
know what i don't even care about the
people who lost part i mean not that i
don't care about the people who lost
parts but that exists for actors it does
but i'm saying i think the whole me too
thing i feel bad for the woman who
doesn't have a green card who's working
in some weird
shop and she's got some you know
[ __ ] boss who's saying if you don't
sleep with me i'm just sending you back
right here probably hasn't even heard of
the metoo movie she's no leverage these
people are very vulnerable and they're
there's no leverage that's who i i hope
things change and shift for them you
know if you want to sleep for someone
for a part then you know you have to
also take ownership of like you know
what this means this to me and yeah
where i'm not saying
you know listen i
i don't know i heard some you know when
you hear it for yourself and you hear
certain types you're like oh god this is
horrible yeah but i was listen i was
very lucky and i didn't really have that
just that one time
you also have a cat like you i can see
and had the parts you've played i bet
i guess i guess i played a cat no i know
but
no but like a feline kind of strong
quality that um
a lot of your characters have had you
play very powerful women bound certainly
uh even show girls i would say there's
there's a strength that they that they
possess that yeah guys maybe are
intimidated by and
[ __ ] like myself pussy's like
scaredy cats
[Music]
you play the jews harp i didn't know
that i know i forgot to bring it i was
gonna bring it because i thought oh
that's always fun oh yeah
and you played under paul simon song
well
yeah it was really herbie hancock was
producing it and he brought me in and
paul simon it was his song yeah oh cool
that was a little intimidating i liked
her but i wanted to play with herbie
because for some reason you know i feel
more comfortable with him well yeah but
paul was a little bit like who's this
girl why are you bringing her in oh
really and i was like hurry this isn't
cool and and he said go ahead play and i
thought oh oh no i started playing he's
like
yeah that's pretty good go in there and
just let's lay a track down and then he
started working it and heard he's like
look he's putting it in oh my god i was
like oh my god but you've been around a
lot of great musicians i know you i've
been around a lot i mean i like music
and i like musicians and i kind of grew
up with a lot of musicians that's my
family i had a lot of musicians in my
family and i remember when we were doing
dreamland you you told me how you have
been friends with bob dylan for a long
time
and i just became friends with bob dylan
when i started doing bound because i was
boxing and he ended up becoming my
sparring partner oh that's so funny he's
a huge boxing fan right and then so
because since then we've become good
pals that's crazy i really like him that
is crazy oh yeah on dreamland
one of the reasons i did is because i
got that cool guitar yeah you got to
play that song too i wrote that song i
wrote that song that was cool that was
good i gotta find that i gotta i got i
don't even have a copy of that song i
haven't seen that in a while do you guys
ever play together you know funny enough
when i made my my only album really mine
because i did a tv i did a movie pray
for rock and roll then i had to go on
tour
dylan so it was really weird i was going
to his house it was the first time i'd
ever gone to his house and i just
finished my
music and i was trying to mix it i had
no idea what i was doing
and then one at the end of the
our visit
he was like so did you bring your record
with you and i was like oh my god he's
like would you like to hear my new
record
and i'm like what
and he played modern times
and i'm listening i'm like oh my god in
my head i'm like why did i ever think i
could make a record this is so insane
and after like playing seven or eight
songs then i'm just like oh my god this
is genius this is so amazing it's like
would you like to play your music now
and i was like oh [ __ ] you bob you know
i was like yeah sure and i did i started
and i was i feel like the answer my
friend is blowing in the breeze yeah
no and so i played i i said fine i was
just so annoyed and i don't think i've
ever been more nervous in my entire life
playing my own music it was the first
person i played it for and i was i
thought i was going to die i'm like oh
my god is this what stage fright feels
like
oh wow and i was like wow i thought i
was going to die what did he say
hey good good steve that's terrible the
first song i played him um i knew was a
good one i knew he would like it just
because tonally it was similar to what
he was doing and i knew my i had a
really good band and stuff
and
he just kept listening to it closer and
he said he said he goes that's very pure
which i thought okay i'll take fury said
and he said did you write that and it
was the one song on the album i didn't
write linda perry wrote it
no he said play me another one and for
some reason that's when i panicked of
course and instead of playing a song
that i wrote that i thought this is
pretty good like i like these lyrics i
played them hands down the weirdest song
i'd ever written oh wow based on it was
my juice harp song oh but it had
christian mcbride who's like the best
stand-up bass player in the world and it
was all about how i learned how to play
the jews harp it was about marie this my
mommy basically who raised me since i
was two this woman from mississippi oh
wow was everything to me wow um but you
did write it you but you wrote a song
about it i wrote a song about her and
the point is it's not even mixed yet i
kept saying how do i mix songs bob like
how do i do this and um
and he listened to about
eight seconds of it and he went
all right well i gotta go now
and i thought oh my god i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die
i literally thought i was gonna die and
then i i was so distraught and i kept
thinking why didn't i stop while i was
ahead like he said this other one was
pure but then to his credit he called me
up and he said he goes i've been
thinking about your music and i said
yeah and he said because that first one
was really pure i said okay the other
one's impure goes in the other one he
goes i thought you need to crank up the
jews harps and i went oh oh that's cool
and he said put juice hops everywhere
and i of course i didn't and there's
another song i said what about this song
he goes put it i didn't even put it i
didn't listen to him i'm such a well
best case scenario he got sort of like
in he got insecure because your song was
so good that he was like damn
he's he's great i love him
he's like you know i don't know there's
a reason he is we just talk and i just
think he's like a eight-year-old kid
yeah after him how often do you talk to
him how often do you see him
um i saw him last time i was in l.a
because i was in a weird mood and i felt
really lost for some reason i was having
a very bad time last time i was in l.a i
know he's become a person like if i'm on
tour if i've been on the road doing some
if i've been in different places when
i'm
when i feel weirdly
like
not lost but out of sync i i tend to
call him
it's like i i guess that was like two
months ago and then i called i
i said i i don't know i was weird i said
i feel lost he said what do you mean
lost
and he was at his studio in l.a yeah and
he was like just come over and so i went
over and he's like i'll find you he's
one of these guys i talk we just talk
and talk i swear to god i don't remember
half the stuff we talk about we just get
into the ethers but we just don't
[ __ ] about things you know and then
he oh he read me some lyrics he was
writing and he was all excited said you
want to hear this i'm like yeah and i'm
thinking oh my god this is so cool like
but you know you could see why he still
loves doing what he does
he's excited and i was like oh i like
this and i like that and that's i never
think about when i'm with him like oh
he's bob dylan i think that's what he
likes i was gonna say that he must
respond to that because
i was like oh my god i mean i started
crying and he started laughing
i need a good woman to kick my ass every
now and then and i was mortified i never
even hit someone before oh my god you
know after i hit
him i never wanted to spar again because
i'm like how do you kind of hit someone
and i'm like i don't want to be hit yeah
i don't want to spar with any more
legends at least yeah right it's like
i'm going to smash you really hard in
the thing i mean i i was mortified when
i hit him and i was like oh my god i
just broke his jaw like yeah you know
all of a sudden you remember that it was
bob dylan and i respond you know i had a
big brother if someone comes after me i
just go like ah yeah and so when bob
just very lightly tapped me i just went
bam i went crazy
good thing you didn't bite his ear it
could have been worse you know that's
the first boxing match i ever went to
was the holyfield one yeah
you saw that in person i was eight rows
away from it i was like oh my god and i
was watching with binoculars at the time
and i literally saw i was like
wait wait is that illegal
and i saw him spit it out on the ground
oh my god and i was like i don't think
that's right i mean and i don't know
much about boxing
i've never seen that before it was so
bizarre and then it got really scary and
it it you thought there was gonna be a
riot or something then we had to leave
what happened oh they they uh shut
everyone out yeah
oh really so they i'm trying to remember
i forget the met they cut they stopped
obviously the match they thought well it
was over but then just the energy in the
place you know you see on the boxing
matches on tv and it looks like it's a
really big arena it's really not about
it no yeah it's not it's just the way it
shot and it just felt very um
i don't know unrestful i mean it just
felt very uh there's a nervous energy
and a scary energy
everyone just had to get out well
there's something very
primal about that that like yeah i
wonder if that taps into a primal fear
where it's like if you witness a human
being bite another human being's ear off
it must it must stir something in you
like something akin to
oh that that might what if that happens
to me or that can have or we're all
capable of doing animals
it's crossed a line of decorum i guess
that's another way to say yes
crossed the line of decorum it was the
line of decorum yeah but he hit his ear
off well it broke a rule like a real
cardinal rule
unwritten rule yeah bite one another um
it's funny my brother and i used to do a
thing uh where we would see how hard we
could bite one another i probably
shouldn't be admitting that and we
really leave him by the teeth yeah or
bite ourselves i was by myself really
yeah i don't think that's weird uh it's
not to me but i'm weird yeah so i'm no
judge of what's weird i mean i think if
you bit someone else it's kind of
because it hurts at least you know where
you could stop you look like a bite from
you would hurt because you have a very
like yeah your teeth i've got canines
i've got fangs
yeah you're a cat you're a [ __ ]
predator
it's so hard i have all these marks
because he's so strong he's like 24
pounds at this point what and he's so
tall like his arms would go up to that
marshall like if he stood up is that
garfield he's huge what's the appeal
with the big cats for you why do you
grab him i didn't know he was he fit in
my palm when i met him i thought he was
so cute he was a rescue yeah he was a
rescue and he was so cute and i loved
him and i thought oh my god i thought he
was just a domestic cat but i think he's
got a bit of african savannah oh which
which is a yeah a huge breed big cat
yeah you know um but he's sweet he's
like a dog cat but he's strong is there
you have such a range as an actress uh
what is there a part that you want to
play that you feel like oh i'm i have a
fantasy to play a part like this or
something that you haven't gotten to do
you know i kind of studied a lot of like
chekov but like the greeks i'd like oh
yeah and i'd like to take any or
something yeah but i'd like to do period
pieces i don't know like the classics or
check off or just something very
different classical like i'd love to
when i get older i'd love to do you know
long day's journey into night oh yeah
like that's i i kind of feel like you
know when i get older there's some
really good parts is there an actor that
that you love that you really admire
that you you would love to work with you
haven't gotten to work with
oh there's a lot yeah not a lot a lot um
women i love kate blanchett i'd love to
work with her yeah uh ben mendelsohn oh
god i think he's amazing
did you watch bloodline yeah he's so
incredible in it god damn and michael
shannon i really like you're always
saying oh we should do something i just
think oh he was in the mueller thing
yeah he's really like surprisingly like
funny and playful he's a very sweet guy
he's a little you know kind of almost
shy at first but when i did kill her joe
oh you did killer joe that's right of
course the tracy letts yeah but he did
the original yes um did tracy let's
direct that no no no no william freed
can you freaking
i eat friedkin wow wow what was that
like old school old school yeah the 70s
he's amazing i mean he's an amazing
director yeah did he talk about it doing
those chase scenes and oh yeah are you
kidding me when i first went to the
exorcist
when i went to go meet him for the job
which you know no thanks to any of my
agents um that's when i again i'm like
why do i have ages you should not have
an agent i feel like you've done your i
don't have an agent but i feel like
right now i want one because i feel like
it's just the world out there i've just
gotten so used to generating my own work
but it would be nice to actually have
someone out there you know helping
um what oh yes
you had a meeting with you i went to go
meet him and he said he goes don't you
have any agents he goes how come no one
sent you into this i said i don't know
man and after you know literally 10
minutes he's like
you're perfect for that
but during the time uh the exorcist had
just come out on blu-ray
and so he it was there and i thought
okay
do i say this i said i'm just going to
geek out i said i'm sorry exorcist i've
seen it maybe a hundred times and i was
going and he's like oh well look at it i
just got the blu-ray he said here i'll
i'll give you i'll sign you your first
blu-ray he wrote you know don't try this
at home
and i thought oh if i don't get the job
i got this like autograph blu-ray
version of the exorcist that's a nice
consolation gift yeah um what is your
most commonly used emoji would you say
i don't know i want to make my own emoji
i i think
i know but i haven't figured i don't
know how to do it
i think i probably use the dancing lady
a lot oh they're like the flamenco
flamenco yeah i think if i use her and
hearts in what context do you use the
flamenco um
like oh you go girl
okay
okay
just to punctuate things in a fun kind
of flourish yeah i don't know emojis
it's such a lazy thing and they don't
really exactly say exactly what i want
them to say i like doing my own drawings
you know the ones that you can draw your
own and yeah disappear yeah it'd be also
embarrassing to send something like that
to bob dylan to send him an emoji he's
not on his cell phone oh oh
how do you communicate with him he
usually he has to call you or you go
through his guy you know smoke signals i
smoke i spoke to him in excel once and
he got mad at me like that's what people
do
he's old school man yeah yeah well yeah
i'm kind of liking
i'm kind of liking talking on the phone
again and it almost feels so intrusive
like if i just does i told you you'd be
like what the [ __ ] yeah are you calling
me it's like that's what people used to
do i forget that phones can do that i
know and i even like it now you could
call and have like be on camera so you
could be like talking to someone it's
nice if you could have uh one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be
really that's your question yeah
yeah and i'll thank you not to judge me
a snack food i'd like a coconut a fresh
coconut that i could drink and i could
eat the meat of and it's very good for
you that's a great idea i love coke
sorry i just scoffed at that no it's a
genius idea it is
you want sweet hydrating hydrating
that's nice and the meat of it is like
satisfying and it tastes really good and
it's good for you uh if you could be a
professional athlete uh what sport would
you play do you like sports
i would like to be one of those gymnasts
who could do all the across the floor
stuff oh yeah the dancing ones the
tumbling stuff yeah but then when
they're dancing and spinning around and
doing all that yeah i think that's
really fun but i like the downhill
skiing guys yeah gals did you dance you
danced a lot in cabaret obviously mm-hmm
uh do you miss that do you miss dancings
um yeah i mean i missed you know i grew
up now i mean ever since i was 14 i was
a dancer yeah um i mean cabaret was fun
dancing it wasn't you know dancing
dancing but it's uh
yeah it was really fun it was really fun
i love i'm like a song and dance yeah at
the end of the day you know so that that
might be something you'd want to do soon
yeah you have an itch if i could play
any part it would be like some boozy old
like blue singer who's like i get to
sing and also do a curb sort of thing at
the same time be like funny improv but
able to be singing be cool yeah at the
same time that would be really fun uh
i'd like to see that um what's your
favorite movie of all time that's an
impossible question so funny you're the
third person in a row who has in some
form shamed me i've never seen anything
no no no no i don't mean what's your
favorite because you do you have one
favorite in the world no it's too it is
hard i i love back to the future i love
stan by me annie hall um yeah i have a
bunch i could i could probably do my top
five but yeah just one is hard
i can't do just one yeah i have probably
like 20. all about eve
you know the wizard of oz
probably the exorcist okay rosemary's
baby
would waiting for government be on that
list i would love i love waiting yeah
yeah um
probably you know lolita yeah um
the the the cooper
anything kubrick of course kubrick yeah
um
oh my god i have so many yeah i don't
know those are good
those are off the top of my head um if
you could live somewhere else where
would it be
i need to live somewhere where there's a
sea a clear sea lutheran maybe a
lutheran no i but i like it there i i
don't know i mean
we can come back to it we can come back
to i mean i like living in different
places i wouldn't stay there long i'd
probably then go somewhere else you you
have a bit of a vagabond yeah a bit of a
gypsy yeah if you could have dinner with
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met
oh my god these are questions you have
to really spend time i'm going to wake
up in the middle of the night
you should have told you should have
sent it right now so unprofessional
um
salvador dali
um probably albert einstein
and maybe david bowie maybe those three
guys together would be interesting yeah
that's a hard question there's so many
people i'd want to know those are great
those are just three magazines i think
i've been reading about all three of
them recently who is your favorite
muppet i mean the obvious answer but you
know cookie monster that's not an
obvious answer why is that obvious oh
just because we've been talking about
cookie yeah
cookies the cookie monster no a lot
people do say that but yeah i like the
cookie i mean i don't know i like you
know elmo and i like
uh grouch
ask her to um if you could have one
superpower what would it be it's always
that question could would you rather fly
or would rather be invisible yeah but
there are other ones that i hadn't
considered like somebody uh penn said
the other day
um i would want to know every language i
would want to be able to speak every
language that would be amazing kind of
cool i hadn't considered that one
yeah that actually is a great one cool
right yeah i would really love that yeah
if you could be one age for the rest of
your life physically this is a very
superficial question uh what would you
pick
physically yeah if you just say that i
guess it's when i was like the strongest
and the i don't really believe in age
um but i physically yes i think that's
fair
i don't know i guess probably when
you're
uh i don't know like 19 or something or
when are you like well i peaked at like
nine months nine months yeah
yeah probably
yeah not nine months because i mean yeah
you're a woman no
after i learned how to skate and stuff i
certainly wouldn't pick 18 because i was
a late bloomer um you were you in
earlier basically you're gonna look that
way i was i still looked like a fetus
when i was eight seventeen oh i thought
you meant just like you had the strength
of that certain age yeah yeah that's and
the stamina and all the things when you
just felt like ah your best
uh
i mean i think when i'm really in a good
healthy space i i feel that way although
as you get older all sounds like oh my
arm hurts yeah
you know what i mean it's like give me
the body flex i know um i don't know i
mean any any year between like you know
15 to probably i don't know 35 i see you
know when you're really
running around crime um
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick a
cat i'd like to be my cat because i
think that would be a fun life yeah i
mean but and you can hang out with
yourself and i get to hang out with me
um you know it depends where you're
living and
what's happening in the world is climate
change stopped are you free oh yeah yeah
everything's fine oh everything's great
yeah yeah you don't have to struggle
unless you don't have to struggle i mean
it'd be fun to be then some sort of bird
like an eagle or something you could fly
around and see the world and speak
different languages
i think i know this one but dogs are
cats
cats yeah that's funny most people are
dogs but um
yeah most people are dumb yes
next question how do you feel about most
people i can cross that one off um the
beatles are the rolling stones
uh probably the beatles yeah yeah i mean
i like the rolling stones but the
beatles and do you ever think about
legacy and and the afterlife things like
that did you have a construct of
what that meant in terms of the
afterlife and you type out like do you
believe in reincarnation in the
afterlife anything yeah i'm not very
religious in any way but i i do believe
in reincarnation you do yes oh cool
oh so so the
the type of reincarnation where you
would become a different person or an
animal
oh this is a very long conversation
lightning round
lightning round reincarnation what do
you think about guys i know i know um i
should have led i should have started
yeah i mean this is kind of that's too
much we'll come back it's a big
conversation just because i've
experienced it myself and you alluded to
that a little bit yeah i mean i've gone
through i don't really believe in
anything until i really witness it or
feel it myself really so like
you know i believe in ghosts because
i've seen them oh man right
how did i not and this earlier how did i
not know this i met like my
past life husband once in this really
strange thing and i've had really weird
experiences so i i had one experience
that was pretty insane was it in a dream
was it no it was in hong kong
yeah yeah i wrote about it in my book i
think i wrote a little bit about it in a
like kind of a blurby sort of way
because i needed more pages that had
nothing to do with my cat story but then
how i found my [ __ ] lost my mind i had
the
i think i wrote about that which was
kind of insane and you were conv how do
you know that that's what it was you
just felt it i mean in a nutshell and
like the the broad strokes basically the
broad strokes was i was in
hong kong and it was very late at night
and i was trying to get back to the
hotel
and all of a sudden i felt something
like my stomach literally like whipped
me around and i was like what this crazy
feeling and i saw the back of this guy's
head and he was a three women and they
went downstairs like they have the
subways at the street and they come up
and i thought that was a strange moment
and all i was i mean i was missing my
boyfriend and blah blah blah
and then also i felt this thing again
and i just grabbed my friend i said
we're following this guy he said what
and i started naming everything i said
this guy is blah blah blah blah blah i
knew everything about him i knew why he
was there i knew how old he was i knew
where he was from it was this like
crazy
thing and when i
like you were possessed with this
knowledge yeah and um
yeah and then i went to the bar and
everything i said was right so you
followed him and and and and he friended
him about it no i just started talking
him and then we just like were in love
with each other and then we ended up
like having this whole relationship but
like it was weird how does your
boyfriend feel about that
well he didn't know
we were really young [ __ ] him he was
cheating on me oh okay with a current
life lover or a past life locker
oh he was with currently oh okay no but
it was a very strange situation like i
knew that and then
in the middle of everything he kept he
was like this sounds crazy because i
know you he goes i feel like you're my
wife oh my god he spoke all these
different languages it was the strangest
experience it's too long it's too long
and a little blurry yeah yeah but it but
did you ever did you keep in touch with
him i did for a little bit cause he
wanted me to come to meet his wife and
his family wow but it was just like this
thing of i don't know how i knew all
this stuff and i started getting images
from the past and he was getting the
same images i've never met this guy oh
my god and he kept saying this is going
to sound insane i'm like just say it and
it was weird it was really strange
wow and had anything like that ever
happened to you before you had a
premonition about something i mean i
have premonitions i mean i i i've had
strange things happen to me where i hear
voices saying get off the plane and i'm
like oh god and then i had to get off
the plane and the plane was faulty
things like that oh my god yeah i can't
believe we wasted all this time on
donuts now i'm like [ __ ] this is the
good this is the stuff i want to talk
about yeah oh [ __ ] well you got to come
back it's a weird thing because you know
people think you're like a weirdo when
you talk about that stuff no no i think
it's
i think it's fascinating i mean i i
would i want to believe in that stuff i
have a real desire to to
believe to believe in it and i'll tell
you the other weird thing that happened
to me is in that song in dreamland i
think i talked about it the in-between
thing that all i don't think i told the
guy when i was writing it but everything
in that dream was true right
in that song was true oh now i gotta go
back and forth you have to listen i know
i should listen to it too but i haven't
seen that movie in a long time
i don't even know what it's about it's
about two kids in a trailer park and uh
yeah that's when you move there i i just
remember playing i played
you played
i played your son he's like so funny
you're my son i know and i was like i
thought you were so pretty i had such a
crush and i was like i'm my mom i'm
that's my mom that doesn't yeah i don't
think you were like i don't want to be
your son no i had you very very young no
you would have had me at 12 or something
yeah thanks for doing this this now i
want to know i feel like we just
scratched
go watch dreamland go read the book
what's your book called again the book
that we've been talking about it's
called in search of cleo how i found my
[ __ ] and lost my mind yeah how could i
forget that title how i found my [ __ ]
in life it's about when my cat went
missing in l.a cleo cleo follow gina on
instagram on the old ig the old ig she's
really fun to follow and uh i'm sure
you'll post
oh yeah that's right you make stupid
comments every now and then you mean
really funny witty comments yeah you
misspoke um yeah yeah really funny witty
stupid clown full and stupid uh i
started following you until i realized
you weren't putting me on and i got my
feelings started
unfollowing oh that'd be oh no well
follow me again and i'll tag you more
i'll be more aware of tag um and uh and
thanks thanks for listening guys
thanks guys thanks for being here yes
been a real who yeah even though you
smell like farts and boogers [ __ ]
fart head
justin fart long did not fart
[Music]
well that happened
is that you why'd you do that well i was
thinking that's her voice gina has a
very adultery adultery yes you did say
that at one point yeah is that uh see
gina is somebody that i'm very
comfortable saying something like that
too
she can roll with that yeah
you know that's the thing know what it
is she's cool uh but i agree she does
have a sultry voice
is
saying someone has a sultry voice is
that
is there anything and potentially
insulting about that
i mean does it does it if you don't know
that you're like
an old boozy like i think
i think of uh like katherine hepburn or
yeah or kathleen durant bancroft and
yeah you know ellen barkley
i would say it has the
i think the most important thing is that
um is that you just read the room and
you just you get a sense from the person
if they would be comfortable and and you
establish a relationship with them
before you say something like you have a
sultry voice like you have you've never
well you haven't met her you could say
yeah but i you don't know where that
well i wouldn't walk up to her and say
hey you have a cell phone no exactly
that would be offensive i don't i would
i would say to you that i have a sultry
voice oh that she is i would tell you
that she has a selfie voice well thank
you the more i say the word sultry the
weirder it sounds like
i know sultry sultry you don't hear that
do you ever do that you say a word yes
enough times and you start to think what
that happens that's a really weird word
papaya is a little bit like that papaya
yeah or uh mung bean what is that it's a
chinese uh this is your eyebrow spazzed
when you said that
mung bean bean bean um that's a tough it
is so it's not fermented but what men
would have if you had to choose a man
with a sultry voice would you say like
barry white or like billy dee williams
yeah that's cell tree yep a male sultry
girl i would whatever you would say rich
like uh baritone it's a rich baritone
rich is good satiny
no yeah maybe i don't know i don't know
well anyway she's a great boy
she's a great sultry voice yeah she
doesn't sound like wallace shawn no oh
speaking of voices
the napoleon dynamite voice wears a
little thin yeah i knew you were going
to say that it does
at first the first ten minutes i thought
this might go on the entire time it's
hard thankfully it didn't
it's hard not to slip into it
occasionally because that's like we say
in the interview that's that's kind of
what we bonded over too we both found it
so funny and i it was also a way for us
to say really immature fun things to
each other without
you know it was almost like gave us
license to call each other fart head and
like booger brain which is like just
sort of fun to say to somebody yeah but
then you think
there's so many people listening to this
and
maybe i should i know that's true you
know edit do a little stuff
it's not just us it's not just about us
being having fun with each other yeah
but i'm glad he had fun but but maybe
find a happy medium with that voice okay
for next time all right now i'm giving
myself a note okay
uh but i i also thought she was talking
a lot about bob dylan and i thought i
kind of get why
bob dylan wants to be her friend you
know she's like a cool friend though
yeah yeah uh it's amazing that she said
curb was her first time really
improvising i know in her career which i
find
crazy because she's so good at it she
seems so comfortable on that show it's
like it's like someone picking up a
basketball and being like all right go
against michael jordan yeah it's like
what i know and we recently talked about
this because the first episode of curb
premiered a couple weeks ago yeah we
were noting the extreme difference
between
some actors on that show who go in like
guns blazing and they're trying to be
funny and the ones who are just
really present and playing
the scene and not trying to
add anything else to it because this the
scenes are the situations are so funny
on that show and gina is a perfect
example of somebody who excels on that
show in my opinion because she's just
being present in the scene she's not
trying to look for jokes or say funny
lines that's true you know she's just
really present um and the main cast
members of that show
the thing they all have in common is
that
they are great at that at that right and
what you're talking about and not
searching for the joke at just being
present and playing the stakes right
playing the intention of the scene um
and
every once in a while they get a guest
star on that show
that uh can match them and do that exact
same thing yeah and that was one of them
and bob
einstein uh rest in peace i know was
great at that that's great yeah but gina
the point is gina is just really like
also seamlessly but it's also a great
story that she tells yeah about how she
got it i know and i never i never
realized that distinction that you made
that you aptly made
uh that the opposite of a roast is a
toast
yeah that really is the opposite yeah it
was i didn't realize that until i said
it so funny
yeah toast
because it and it's so easy for a toast
to become a roast i suppose and vice
versa uh well i feel like a lot of
drunken wedding toasts turn into roasts
um kind of by accident maybe you know i
couldn't get through my
i included a little roasty material in
my toast of damien when he got married
our older brother
and i
could not get through it because you're
too emotional it's too emotional because
men we've talked about those tend to
they have a history of
in general i don't generalize men and
women but they i i'll just talk about
myself you can say something bad about
men that's true that's allowed
men repress the emotions more more so
that i think than women or i'll say i do
i did anyway at the time and i was um
not anymore now they just come on out so
it was so when emotions come on they
spill over and they come on really
quickly and
like without much warning so i remember
being like the damn breaking yeah i
remember being halfway through that and
just stopping i remember being like i
remember saying everything like
yeah like you might not be able to do
that i was like i said something funny i
don't remember about david or i thought
it was funny and like uh and then
i i had to say something like um
to test his his wife is like please take
good care of him because he's always
taking care of us or something like that
and i was like
and tess
oh
and i remember just feeling like you
know when your throat like closes to
like
your throat tries to prevent your like
esophagus prevents the emotions from
coming out and it also probably sounds
like when you just said test and yeah it
probably sounded to people like
you're so moved by the nice things
you're about to say about her
that you can't get that's when you get
choked up it's fun it's like dania i can
talk about damien in long terms but but
once i started talking about her
don't get me started on tests yeah that
was hard to come i don't know if i
finished that problem i think i did i
was like you did i think i was like
weeping though by the end um
uh speaking of
uh brothers she you asked her at one
point what her brother does for a living
because she was talking about how she uh
wrote a book oh yeah
and she said [ __ ] so many times
that's
and it was it's weird to say [ __ ]
obviously we were talking about the cat
yeah so we can say it but it's dogs or
[ __ ]
i know but it's but it's such a an
extreme word because of the other
meaning well what other meaning well
we'll talk about it later
uh so you're like oh what does he do for
a living and she goes uh oh he um
he has a thing on the internet now with
color
and you just go okay
and i know i knew for sure you didn't
know what she was talking about but it's
also like she knew what she was talking
about
and i quote he has a thing on the
internet now with color
what does that mean
okay
i forgot about that that's when we were
running out of time a little bit too
yeah and it was that before after she
had said the stuff about reincarnation
oh that was at the very end uh-huh that
was like wait what wait why
why are we talking about this now she
was talking about the
thing what do you think that could mean
he's a thing on the internet with color
uh
like i i remember thinking at the time
like oh like he does youtube videos
about like explaining color spell like
an art an artist maybe with colors and
maybe like a jackson pollock for youtube
i don't know maybe um she talked about
holding her ground with predatory men
and how she does the thing like yes
which stares them down with like the
thing that animal cat yeah yes i thought
that was
fascinating i know and also you know the
people
often use the term badass [ __ ] now
that's a very common thing you hear all
or bad ass [ __ ] or badass [ __ ] do
people say bish anymore i don't think so
i think that's out
yeah i think maybe it's just badass now
this 2019 thing oh she's badass mm-hmm
you hear that all you hear badasses
elizabeth warren you hear about
pretty much every woman who does
anything like noteworthy or cool or yes
or um impressive badass peter perrone
that's the go-to yeah that's the go-to
character
um but i would say in the traditional
sense of the term badass
she actually is a badass yes that
doesn't she strikes totally that way yes
and i almost referred to her thusly
because that move is badass it's like
absolutely like staring someone down to
get the power back but people have
overused that word when we were kids the
term badass kind of implied like
rambo is badass someone who's like tough
and yeah um
you know holds their ground physically
you know she has a history of playing
badasses i guess so and she's probably
so good at that because she is naturally
badass she is i think that i think
you're right that term definitely
applies to her at one point you did
yours you you started to do a bob dylan
impression and you bailed out right away
it was so funny
you got hate because you were talking
about how
how he reacted to her
music that she played for him oh yeah
and you try to impression you go hey
good stuff and then you go that was
terrible
you couldn't commit to one line of it
hey that was good stuff really that was
terrible
well it's such it's such a common
impression
and i i didn't want to
do a bad version of a common impression
they could hey i i was you don't know
like cartoonish impressions
because they're friends right that's
true it's insulting and she did a good
impression of she did she did his voice
you know why because it was uh nuan it
was it was subtle yeah and and i imagine
i like her improv and curve yes yeah
she's new ones she's a good actor she's
a good actress yes
um i'm very curious to hear jew's heart
music
because i i don't know about you
but i haven't heard jew's heart music
since do you remember yes
yes of course it was our father had a
colleague yes named we're not going to
say her name okay but my dad would
because i don't remember my i remember
my dad would often have oh yeah um
colleagues he was a philosophy professor
uh colleague in college and he would
often have
i think it's fair to say eccentric
colleagues over for dinner that's very
fair
and
one
such dinner he had a colleague over who
was um an older lady a single lady
who
in lieu of bringing a traditional gift
for dinner like a bottle of wine or
flowers or chocolates or whatever
she brought this cassette tape and we're
like oh what is this
and she was like i would like you to
play it and she was very
oh my god stately yes yes and and so my
dad was a bit like
yeah my dad put on the tape and
what was on it was the weirdest sounding
i never heard of it it was what it was
we were kids we should we were kids but
it was juice harp music it was just a
single guitar which i had never heard of
that solo juice and it was just like
wait wait
i think it was her playing oh it was oh
maybe it was i think it was and uh juice
harp is it may if you are unfamiliar
with the sound
if you listen to it if you google it
you'll it may be familiar to you in in
mixed in with other music what's your
impression of it it ain't down down down
it's it was like damn yeah it was like
twangy twain it was sort of like a mix
of a banjo and a harp and then yes it'll
sound familiar only in the context of
other with other instruments like i
think in fact bob dylan uses you'll hear
it in like i think mumford and sons bob
dylan but solo juice
yeah that you may never have heard it's
a weird sound and it's an even weirder
gift to bring to someone's house and
then didn't she whip out a juice harp at
one point and and kind of show you or i
don't remember i think you're or it was
a nightmare i had later that night or no
maybe she just showed us how to play it
like and you play it in your mouth you
put it
in in your teeth kind of and like uh and
like you
really yeah you like pluck it from
between your teeth it's an interesting
i'm curious interesting way to play her
music hear her choose heart music yeah
anyway there's such different there's
like
sorry there was like a 25-year gap
between the first time i heard about
juice harp and now this the second time
i heard about it i wonder why they call
it a jew's harp to it i don't know if
it's not of course that sounds
maybe offensive but uh that's the name
of it that's the name we have to say and
it's like jew uh there's also a
jew jewish choke there's a jerusalem
artichoke i'm thinking of a jew joke
at some point um but it wasn't funny
that those two different people you
there's been so few times in your life
where you've heard that instrument
mentioned and it's those two those two
and they're such different people
different people
when she started talking about meeting
her a husband she had in a former life
and oh yeah i wanted to know more about
that for one thing but also i thought it
was hilarious when you asked if the guy
that she met was cheating on you said
she said was he cheating on you with a
current life lover or a past life lover
she's like currently she's just like
matter of fact yeah
or maybe didn't hear it uh
i do believe in that stuff like do you
ever meet anyone you're like god i feel
like
this is not the first time we've
encountered each other i've had that
feeling but i've never thought i know
this person yeah that's definitively
it's it's different than being like
there's something
familiar about this experience or it's
like deja vu i think i've experienced a
version of deja vu i've never had an
extreme like the thing that set her
story apart from that would you do
anything about him yes and he knew
everything about her that's that is how
do you that's strange that's hard for me
to believe i mean i want to believe it
him knowing things about her made a
little bit more sense because she's a
known person and you could google all
this
you weren't in show girls were you she's
like how the [ __ ] do you know that he's
like joe and you
yeah yeah
he'd been following her around
yeah but it's harder to justify
her unless he just lied unless she was
like wait a minute you weren't born on
february 10th and he was like oh my god
i find it extremely difficult to believe
but
at the same time i really want to
believe it i do too i hope she's i know
right it'd be great to have other but
then you think a friend of mine said
that they had a
they had a similar experience with
somebody uh with a man and she said it
was less so i was like oh so it was
romantic he was like right and she said
uh it was it was intense and extreme but
from my end it felt more maternal like i
had been his mother in a past life so
that's interesting to think about like
let's say our relationship with our
mother
what if in another life you guys in
other forms uh
get together let's read a letter
okay this is a letter from brenda lee
c
subject accent challenge uh oh
hi long boys
i love your podcast and i've been a fan
of you justin since a teen
i am from south africa and wondering
haha if you can do i accident
it's very
south african accent is it's just a lot
it's it's similar to australia
i love the relationship between you
between you two that's ironic
uh very much like my own with my brother
which is die hard quick movie reference
for life she said that but we'll never
admit it in words ah spy
with several e's b well let's hear your
south africa okay challenge accepted and
here's the real challenge do it and
don't make it offensive
that's impossible
um
it's it's there's this in it there's
this in it and i don't know
i don't know the difference between yeah
sometimes i'll say that that's a little
lost it is australia well sometimes when
i say it's
if i do
if i do the
australian accent i'll do it like that
and not as good
as or if i'm not thinking about it if
i'm not really trying who's the south
african person that you can reference
like um uh uh ernie ells is he south i
think he's south african the golfer or
um um you know there's that actor from
district nine in
charlotte charlotte
in this
you know when i'm watching that movie of
course on i start i start giving it a
shot it's like not is it's australian
it's like a bad australian it's not bad
oh so maybe it's just your australian
accent that's what i said well i was
going to say sometimes when i do
australian for people they say
for australians they'll say the first
thing that they'll say is either
it's it's a kiwi this is new zealand
or they'll say
oh freaking oh yeah so maybe i should
just do my australian accent and and
it'll be like a good south african
accent
well i think they're both probably
pretty bad oh thanks for writing in
thanks brenda lisey
if you guys want to write in our email
address is life is short at
wondering.com right in with any uh any
and all concerns
uh excellent challenges so thank you to
brenda and thank you to our badass bish
yeah
we've had some bad ass badasses we sure
have olivia's a badass kobe's the toby
he's a badass whoa jesus
um but yeah
she's a yes queen she's badass um thanks
for listening everybody thanks to
wallace shawn for that incredibly
thoughtful letter um
and uh hopefully we'll work we will work
with him one day and and we'll see you
all next week
thanks guys
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco
senior producers michelle miche lans
our audio engineer is sergio enriquez
are executive producers of martial louis
and anon lopez for
wondering
[Music]
you've never heard that
pass the duchy on the left hand side
you're making it up past the douchey
hammer though i swear to god past the
doochie yeah what is that like a joint i
think so
it has to do on the left-hand side yeah
i think so it might be the right-hand
side
i guess if you are making it up it's
impressive that you're right oh i
why would i have just hummed it
why would it have
been something that that reminded me of
oh yeah
pass the doochie on the left-hand side
look it up on your phone no why
i don't want it on my head
it's already gonna be in your head don't
you want to hear the actual song now
i guarantee you i don't remember
tomorrow but i don't hear it again oh
really
you